Yo tendría que estar muerto hace 30 años.
Soy un sobreviviente.
Uno de los miles
de conscriptos argentinos,
soldados no profesionales,
que fuimos enviados a una guerra
que nunca debió ocurrir.
Pasé 60 días
sobreviviendo en un pozo congelado,
en condiciones infrahumanas,
junto a mi compañero Roberto,
sin alimentación sólida
y perdí 20 kilos de peso corporal.
Tuvimos claramente, tres enemigos:
el clima, los ingleses
y, tristemente, nuestros propios jefes,
que nos trataron con un desprecio
por la condición humana
que nos costaba entender.
Claro, ante ese panorama tan duro,
donde no sabíamos si íbamos a sobrevivir
a esa desnutrición y a esos maltratos,
empezaron a surgir fortalezas,
no sé de dónde.
Empezamos a tomar decisiones.
A tomar decisiones para no morirnos.
No era mucho lo que podíamos hacer,
pero empezamos a hacerlo,
a trabajar en el día a día.
Cosas simples como mantener
ese pozo lo menos mojado posible,
también escaparnos al pueblo,
10 kilómetros,
a tratar de revolver
los tachos de basura de los isleños,
o romper algún galpón, desesperados.
Y 10 kilómetros de vuelta.
Eso lo dejamos de hacer rápido
por dos motivos:
el gasto calórico era enorme
y conseguíamos pocas cosas
y los castigos eran inhumanos.
Si nos encontraban nos "estaqueaban".
El estaqueo era una crucifixión al suelo,
atados de muñecas y tobillos,
con la campera abierta, como animales,
durante horas.
Vi a por lo menos 15 o 20 compañeros
en esas condiciones,
por ir a robar comida.
Esta foto, que es muy impresionante,
son mis hermanos sobrevivientes
de la compañía.
Ellos bailaron con la más fea.
Ellos recibieron lo peor del ataque.
Fantasmas. Los compañeros del pueblo,
que nos veían en esas condiciones,
después, años más tarde, nos enteramos
que nos decían "los zombis".
Todos héroes, todos sobrevivientes,
todos hermanos.
Aprendí muchas cosas con esa experiencia,
aprendí a ser más humilde,
aprendí a escuchar
y a pedir ser escuchado.
Aprendí a valorar cada cosa
con mucha intensidad.
Y, sobre todo, empecé
descubrir fortalezas
que ni imaginaba que yo mismo tenía.
Pero hablando de aprendizajes,
uno de los más interesantes
ocurrió a la vuelta,
cuando los ingleses
nos llevan como prisioneros de guerra,
en este trasatlántico, el Canberra,
rumbo a Madryn.
Ahí pasé una semana a bordo de esa nave,
y yo era traductor,
y lo que pasó ahí fue com
un alucinante experimento antropológico.
4122 prisioneros argentinos
que veníamos custodiados
por los mismos ingleses
con los que habíamos estado matándonos
la semana anterior.
Era una experiencia surrealista.
Y yo pensé, antes de subir al barco,
cuando me enteré que estaban los ingleses,
dije, listo, acá se pudre todo,
nos matamos a trompadas.
Pero mi sorpresa fue grande
cuando me encuentro al poco tiempo
traduciendo conversaciones
entre mis compañeros y los ingleses,
conversaciones amables,
conversaciones con mucha curiosidad
acerca de cómo había sido el otro lado.
Conversaciones de música.
Escuchábamos Pink Floyd y Genesis nosotros
y ellos también.
Y en el barco la música era eso,
lo que se escuchaba en los parlantes.
Y ahí aprendí una enorme lección:
aprendí que sería imposible enfrentar
a un enemigo una vez que
uno lo conoce, una vez
que el enemigo deja de ser anónimo,
y que los enemigos son siempre anónimos.
Y también pensé
que si uno pusiera a convivir
a grupos de jóvenes
de países en conflicto,
y que los jóvenes se conozcan y dialoguen,
como hicimos ingleses y argentinos,
a bordo de ese barco,
habría quizás menos guerras en el mundo
y menos jóvenes ingresando a ejércitos.
Las tareas a bordo del barco
fueron intensas,
yo recorría el barco traduciendo.
Hasta tareas en quirófano
que fueron muy impresionantes.
Yo tapé la historia.
Cuando volví de la guerra tapé
y no hablé durante 20 años.
Fue recién en 2001 con la crisis,
la catástrofe argentina de 2001,
yo tenía una actividad comercial,
un negocio en la ciudad de Venado Tuerto,
Santa Fe, donde vivo.
Y estaba como millones de argentinos,
sufriendo un estrés impresionante,
y en ese marco tuve
mi primer pesadilla de combate.
Nunca había soñado.
Ahí sueño que estoy en un pozo
junto a cinco compañeros,
la mañana del 12 de junio,
los ingleses ya habían tomado la cima,
y nos está lloviendo
toneladas de fierro caliente,
morterazos y cañones,
y todo está temblando como un terremoto.
Hay dos amigos muertos afuera,
que no alcanzaron a entrar,
tenemos a Roberto con esrquilas
en cadera e intestino,
la aceleración final de esos proyectiles
es estremecedora,
yo empiezo a rezar.
Todo esto está durando 8 horas,
de 8 de la mañana a 4 de la tarde.
La sensación es como que
están cayendo vehículos del cielo,
y no paraba de temblar,
y yo empiezo a rezar
como despidiéndome de este mundo,
mis amigos me acompañan.
Y mientras estoy rezando,
me vienen en cámara lenta
imágenes de mi familia,
jugando con mi abuela y con mi vieja.
Y, en esa instancia,
dentro de la pesadilla,
me suena un teléfono celular,
era el gerente del banco que me decía:
"Miguel te cierro la cuenta,
tenés demasiados cheques rechazados".
Ese día me di cuenta
de que no podía seguir tapando
y pedí ayuda.
Empecé a hablar.
Los primeros dos años
con tratamiento psicológico.
Después hablar y bueno,
terminé escribiendo un libro.
Pero los recuerdos,
la pesadilla no vino sola,
vino acompañada de todos los desórdenes
por estrés post-traumático
que uno puede imaginar.
Estuve muy deprimido, perdí mucho peso,
y estuve 2 años con imágenes invasivas,
recuerdos recurrentes
que no paraban de venir a mi mente.
Pero al igual que en el pozo,
donde con Roberto
empezamos a tomar decisiones
en el día a día,
yo en esa instancia, donde pensé
que me estaba volviendo loco,
empecé también a trabajar en el día a día
y a estar mejor.
Las cosas que hice
pueden parecer hasta graciosas,
yo lloraba a la mañana
y hasta tuve sueños donde me suicidaba.
Y en esos momentos,
me forzaba a levantarme de la cama,
a salir a correr, a nadar,
clases de teatro, masaje,
reiki, flores de Bach,
hasta cura sanador.
Pero al final del día me di cuenta,
al igual que en el pozo,
que las riendas de mi vida
las tenía que tener yo.
Y fue así como gradualmente
me fui empezando a sentir mejor.
Sabía que dentro de ese camino sanador
que yo tenía que empezar a recorrer,
que ya había empezado a recorrer,
era necesario volver al lugar,
volver a las islas.
La vida me cruzó con James Peck,
un hermano de la vida,
una persona que cambió mi vida.
James está acá entre nosotros,
es muy tímido, no quiere que lo señale,
pero nos está acompañando.
Él vino a Buenos Aires con estos cuadros,
él había pintado nuestro sufrimiento,
todo el dolor por el cual pasamos
los conscriptos argentinos,
él lo había capturado en una tela
y nosotros éramos parte
de sus propios fantasmas.
La vida nos hermanó,
James es una persona muy valiente,
es una persona con libertad
e independencia de pensamiento.
James recibió el DNI argentino
de mano de la presidenta el año pasado,
yo tuve el honor acompañarlo.
Pero lo que James no me contó
en ese primer viaje,
donde yo vuelvo con toda mi familia,
era que su papá, Terry Peck,
había combatido contra mí.
Terry había sido el vaqueano
que guió a los soldados ingleses
hasta donde estábamos nosotros,
y terminó combatiendo
a escasos metros nuestro.
Lo conozco en el año 2000,
una persona increíble.
Nos subimos
a los campos de batalla juntos,
nos mostramos dónde habíamos estado,
brindamos a la memoria
de nuestros compañeros muertos
y encontramos terreno en común,
donde nos habíamos enfrentado
en una guerra innecesaria.
Y también nos intercambiamos boinas,
como se ve en esta foto.
Lo recuerdo con mucha cariño.
Terry falleció hace 6 años,
y estoy seguro de
que si él estuviera viendo esto
estaría con la misma sonrisa
que en la foto.
Una de las postales
más emocionantes de la historia
ocurrió en los últimos días de la guerra.
Yo voy como intérprete también,
me ordenan ir en una patrulla,
a una casita en una granja
que se suponía que estaba transmitiendo
a la flota por radio.
Salimos bien temprano, estaba co
gelado todo,
la helada era tremenda,
y estábamos muy desnutridos,
ya estábamos mareados
con cualquier desplazamiento,
me pesaba el fusil.
Y llegamos a la casa moribundos.
Ya a esta altura, principios de junio,
tuvimos un compañero que se murió
de la hipotermia y de la desnutrición,
antes de que llegaran los ingleses.
Otros cuatro que pisaron una mina
en una de esas caminatas
y también murieron.
Y otros cinco o seis que se pegaron tiros
en los pies para ser evacuados.
Esa era la situación terminal
en la cual yo llego a esa casita
y al entrar me alimento con desesperación
y grito en inglés
para ver si había alguien,
y lo primero que identifico
es el olor de esa casa,
un olor muy familiar.
Y me llama la atención
un pullover inglés muy lindo,
que me pongo en la nariz
y me conecta con mi propio hogar.
Y sentí como que había alguien
en esa casa que me protegía,
que me decía: "Ya falta poco Miguel,
vas a volver, vas a estar bien".
Y cuando me iba con ese pullover
con el que me sentí más fuerte,
me dio protección,
yo dije: "Acá voy a volver algún día
y con esta gente voy a hablar".
La vida me dio esa increíble oportunidad,
25 años después
se lo devuelvo a Lisa,
el pullover era del papá.
Me dijo: "Mi papá murió
por el estrés de esta guerra,
pocos años después",
y yo le contesté: "Mi mamá también".
Fue un momento sublime,
tomamos el té con ella
y, cuando nos íbamos,
John, uno de los isleños,
en el vehículo 4x4,
mientras cruzábamos el río,
me dijo algo que me llenó el corazón:
"Sentite orgulloso Miguel,
estás construyendo puentes".
(Aplausos)
Creo que esa es la clave
para cualquier relación humana,
construir menos paredes y más puentes.
Cuando llegamos al regimiento en La Plata,
al volver, los militares
nos dieron arengas,
nos hicieron firmar
declaraciones juradas
para que no contemos nada.
Estaban todos los familiares afuera
desesperados por noticias,
y los familiares de los muertos,
que los militares les daban
informaciones esquivas,
les decían que iban a llegar mañana,
y estaban muertos.
Ese recuerdo me estruja el corazón
y desde acá los abrazo a todos ellos,
esas familias han sufrido muchísimo.
Y me encuentro en la multitud
con mi hermano,
que también había saltado
la pared del regimiento,
y me lleva hasta el auto
donde estaban mis viejos
y yo voy corriendo
por esa calle adoquinada de La Plata,
en el frío, en junio,
y escucho los gritos de mi vieja,
y casi que no la veo,
veo como un aura, y me zambullo
entre esos brazos temblorosos.
Fue un momento increíble,
este fue el momento
más emocionante de mi vida.
Y me vienen a la mente
los momentos duros de mi vida,
y me viene siempre este flash.
Y en los momentos lindos también.
Es como una virgen que me acompaña.
Yo cuando volví,
mi cuerpo estaba diezmado,
había perdido 20 kilos,
tenía los dientes flojos por el escorbuto,
el cuellito flaco, estaba esquelético,
las plantas de los pies necrosadas por
el congelamiento.
Entré en un estado al que yo ahora razono
como la "euforia del sobreviviente".
Me ponía el despertador temprano,
aunque no tuviera nada que hacer,
para disfrutar la vida.
Salía, mi cuerpo destrozado,
pero estaba con una fortaleza
y una alegría de vivir inmensas.
Salía a la calle y todo
me emocionaba profundamente,
el olor a pasto recién cortado,
el canto de los pájaros,
hasta los colores de la tele
me parecían emocionantes.
Y la gente que me venía a visitar
me decía: "Estás distinto, estás mejor".
Y yo les decía: "Claro que estoy mejor".
Pero en ese momento
no sabía cómo explicarlo,
era esta "euforia del sobreviviente".
Se hizo una fiesta en casa
con amigos y familia.
¿Vieron "Naúfrago" la de Tom Hanks?
Cuando él vuelve de la isla,
que le hacen una fiesta,
fue exactamente igual.
Yo estaba en otra frecuencia,
venía de un retiro espiritual,
y venía con todos esos aprendizajes,
aprendizajes que no se aprenden
en muchas vidas ni en ninguna universidad.
Yo venía con esa fortaleza
y me sentía muy fuerte,
y en esa fiesta todos tomaban
y hablaban fuerte.
Y yo quería estar solo.
Me fui a la cocina
y prendí las hornallas
y así calentándome las manos
empecé a pensar para adentro:
"Vas a tener que mantener esta fortaleza
porque ellos por más amor que le pongan
les va a costar entender
la profundidad de tu historia,
vas a estar solo con este recuerdo
toda la vida".
Y también pensé: si yo puedo congelar
esta euforia del sobreviviente,
esta valoración de lo simple
que estoy sintiendo ahora,
porque yo veía a toda la gente
viviendo vidas como aletargadas,
estresadas por cosas materiales,p
hasta aburridas,
y yo estaba con todo este aprendizaje
y estaba consciente de
que en el ser consciente
de lo preciosa que es la vida,
iba a estar mi principal handicap,
iba a estar mi fortaleza.
Y que iba a tener una vida distinta,
iba a tener una vida más feliz.
30 años después,
esta sensación está intacta.
La "euforia del sobreviviente" está igual
y me da mucho orgullo, me llena de emoción
haber venido hoy
a compartir mi "euforia del sobreviviente"
con todos Uds.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)